Much of the United States "springs forward" on Sunday, March 9th, for daylight saving time.
美国大部分地区将于3月9日周日“提前”进入夏令时。
Worldwide, many other countries also observe daylight saving time, starting and ending on different dates.
在全球范围内，许多其他国家也实行夏令时，但开始和结束的日期各不相同。
The time change can leave people tired and perhaps unhappy the next day.
时间变化可能会让人第二天感到疲倦，甚至可能心情不佳。
But it also might even harm health.
但它甚至可能对健康有害。
Some studies have found an increase in heart attacks and strokes right after the March time change.
一些研究发现，在3月时间变化后，心脏病发作和中风的数量有所增加。
However, there are ways to ease the effects of the time change, including getting more sunshine.
不过，有一些方法可以减轻时间变化的影响，包括多晒太阳。
The light helps reset your circadian rhythm for healthful sleep.
光线有助于重新调整你的昼夜节律，实现健康睡眠。
In the U.S., daylight saving time begins Sunday at 2:00 in the morning.
在美国，夏令时于周日凌晨2:00开始。
The time change will reverse on November 2 when clocks "fall back" as daylight saving time ends.
时间变化将于11月2日逆转，届时夏令时结束，时钟“回拨”。
The state of Hawaii and most of the state of Arizona do not make the spring change.
夏威夷州和亚利桑那州的大部分地区不实行春季时间调整。
Those areas remain on standard time along with Puerto Rico, American Samoa, Guam and the U.S. Virgin Islands.
这些地区与波多黎各、美属萨摩亚、关岛和美属维尔京群岛一样，保持标准时间。
Some people try to prepare for the change to daylight saving time by going to bed a little earlier two or three nights ahead.
有些人试图通过提前两三天晚上早睡来为夏令时变化做准备。
But with a third of American adults already not getting the suggested seven hours of nightly sleep, catching up can be difficult.
但由于已有三分之一的美国成年人无法达到建议的每晚七小时睡眠，补觉可能很困难。
The brain has a kind of clock that is set by exposure to sunlight and darkness.
大脑有一种时钟，由暴露在日光和黑暗中设定。
This clock, known as the circadian rhythm, is on a roughly 24-hour cycle.
这个时钟，即昼夜节律，大约以24小时为一个周期。
It governs when we become sleepy and when we are more wakeful.
它控制着我们何时感到困倦，何时更加清醒。
The rhythms change with age.
节律会随着年龄变化。
This is one reason that early-to-rise young children turn into hard-to-wake teenagers.
这就是为什么早睡早起的小孩会变成难叫醒的青少年原因之一。
Morning light resets the rhythm.
晨光可以重置节律。
By evening, levels of a hormone called melatonin begin to increase, leading to tiredness.
到了晚上，一种叫做褪黑素的激素水平开始上升，导致困倦。
Too much light in the evening - that extra hour from daylight saving time - delays the melatonin increase.
晚上光线过多——夏令时多出的那一小时——会延迟褪黑素的增加。
As a result, the cycle gets delayed.
结果，周期被推迟了。
The circadian rhythm affects more than sleep.
昼夜节律影响的不只是睡眠。
It also influences heart rate, blood pressure, hormone releases and other systems.
它还影响心率、血压、激素释放和其他系统。
Sleep deprivation, or lack of sleep, is linked to heart disease, weight conditions, problems with thinking and remembering, and more.
睡眠不足或缺乏睡眠与心脏病、体重问题、思维和记忆障碍等有关。
Deadly car crash numbers increase the first few days after the spring time change, a study of U.S. traffic deaths says.
一项对美国交通死亡人数的研究显示，春季时间变化后的头几天，致命车祸数量增加。
The risk of crashes is highest in the morning, it found.
研究发现，车祸风险在早晨最高。
Researchers suggested sleep deprivation might be responsible.
研究人员认为睡眠不足可能是原因。
The time change also has a link to the heart.
时间变化也与心脏有关。
The American Heart Association points to studies that suggest an increase in heart attacks on the Monday after daylight saving time begins, and in strokes for two days afterward.
美国心脏协会指出，有研究表明，夏令时开始后的星期一心脏病发作增加，之后两天中风增加。
Doctors already know that heart attacks, especially severe ones, are a bit more common on Mondays generally - and in the morning, when blood is more likely to clot.
医生们已经知道，心脏病发作，尤其是严重的心肌梗死，通常在星期一更常见——而且在早晨，血液更容易凝固。
Researchers do not know why the time change would add to that Monday connection.
研究人员不知道时间变化为何会加剧这种周一关联。
But it is possible the sudden circadian change influences other issues such as high blood pressure in people already at risk.
但突然的昼夜节律变化可能会影响其他问题，比如已有风险人群的高血压。
To prepare for daylight saving time, experts offer some advice.
为了应对夏令时，专家们提供了一些建议。
Slowly move bedtimes about 15 or 20 minutes earlier for several nights before the time change.
在时间变化前的几个晚上，将就寝时间逐渐提前15或20分钟。
Try to rise earlier the next morning, too.
第二天早上也要尝试早起。
Go outside for early morning sunshine the first week of daylight saving time.
夏令时第一周，到户外享受清晨的阳光。
This is another way to help reset your body's clock.
这是帮助重置身体时钟的另一种方法。
Start daily activities, like dinner or exercise, a little earlier.
将日常活动，如晚餐或锻炼，稍微提前。
This may help tell your body to start getting used to the new conditions, sleep experts suggest.
睡眠专家建议，这有助于告诉你的身体开始适应新的条件。
Daytime sleeping, the drug caffeine and light from phones and other electronic devices can make an earlier bedtime even harder.
白天睡觉、咖啡因以及手机和其他电子设备的光线会使早睡变得更加困难。
Americans have discussed ending daylight saving time.
美国人一直在讨论取消夏令时。
But so far, no official changes have been made.
但到目前为止，还没有做出任何正式改变。
Health groups such as the American Medical Association and American Academy of Sleep Medicine believe it is time to end time changes.
美国医学协会和美国睡眠医学学会等健康组织认为，是时候结束时间变更了。
The groups suggest that staying with standard time year-round works better for human biology and sleep needs.
这些组织建议，全年保持标准时间更符合人类生物学和睡眠需求。
I'm Caty Weaver.
我是凯蒂·韦弗。